kelsey obviously i am incredibly curious  about this  paramount plus version of frasier what  can you tease people about the series  and when do you start filming  uh well we don't actually have a date  when we're going to start filming we're  still  kind of breaking the story a little bit  we're doing a polish now  uh we we think we're going to get most  of the actors back i  i'm fairly i'm certainly hopeful that we  will  and i'm fairly confident that they'll  come back uh  we have a story to tell you know that  can actually be told with or without  them honestly but  it's i want them back because that's  what i always dreamed of i thought we  should explore all their lives and their  third act  and so that's that is my hope but uh  when will we see a fraser  probably in the first quarter of next  year